Well, two big things, I guess. First is that we voted Senders, the C++ asynchronous framework, into C++26. And the second is that we design-approved Reflection for C++26. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast episode 189, recorded on July 3rd, 2024. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host Bryce, we chat about the ISO C++ committee meeting that just took place in St. Louis, as well as our upcoming conference trip to CPP North. Look at that view, folks. You had a nice view before, but it's even better now. Yes, and in fact, I've been working hard to figure out how to position my desk in this room so that I can show off the beautiful view of Manhattan and also not have my screen be like super backlit. But there's just really no option
嗯，我想有两件大事。首先是我们投票将 C++ 异步框架 Senders 纳入了 C++26 标准。其次是我们设计批准了 C++26 的反射功能。欢迎收听 ADSP 播客第 189 期，录制于 2024 年 7 月 3 日。我是 Connor，今天和我的联合主持人 Bryce 一起，聊聊刚刚在圣路易斯举行的 ISO C++ 委员会会议，以及我们即将参加的 CPP North 会议。看看那个景色，各位。你们之前看到的景色就很不错，但现在更棒了。是的，事实上，我一直在努力研究如何摆放房间里的书桌，既能展示曼哈顿的美景，又不会让我的屏幕出现严重的背光。但真的没有办法
for not having a backlit screen here unless I like go in the closet. Well, it's been a while since we've chatted. How did the move go? How is the new place? How's the view? The view does look fantastic, folks. You'll have to post a photo for the people, for the listeners.
让屏幕不背光，除非我躲进壁橱里。嗯，我们已经有一段时间没聊天了。搬家怎么样？新住处如何？景色怎么样？景色看起来确实棒极了，各位。你得给听众们发张照片看看。
The move is going well. Going? It's still going? We talked like a month ago. No, we moved in a week before the C++ St. Louis committee meeting. And so we were here for like six days. And then I went to the St. Louis committee meeting. And then my girlfriend went to Florida, to where my parents are, to go to play at the
搬家进行得很顺利。进行中？还在进行吗？我们大概一个月前聊过。不，我们在 C++ 圣路易斯委员会会议前一周搬进来的。所以我们在这里待了大约六天。然后我就去了圣路易斯参加委员会会议。接着我女朋友去了佛罗里达，我父母住在那儿，去那里的网球学院打球。哦，真高级。我告诉她，你看，我们俩的领地意识都很强。这个新公寓需要成为一个共享空间。如果我们中有一个人在搬家后独自在这里住了一周，我们肯定会做出各种各样的独断决定。然后另一个人回来时，就没法推翻这些决定了。所以我说，要么你跟我一起去圣路易斯，要么我不去圣路易斯，
tennis academy there. Ooh, fancy. I told her that, look, we're both very territorial people. And this new apartment needs to be like a shared space. And if one of us is in this new apartment for like a week right after we moved in without the other one, we're going to make all sorts of executive decisions. And the other person is going to come back. And there's going to be no reversing those executive decisions. So I said either you got to come with me to St. Louis, I got to not go to St. Louis,
要么你去别的地方做点别的事。她选择了最后一个选项。但出了一些小问题。公寓里的两台空调机刚到就坏了。哦，不。但房东在派人修理方面做得很好，空调维修人员在我出发去机场前刚到，嗯，我是说去圣路易斯，我想，是的，是的，去圣路易斯，然后他们把公寓里的断路器
or you got to go somewhere else and do something else. And she picked the last option. But a couple of slight issues. Two of the AC units in the apartment were dead on arrival. Oh, no. But the landlord's been very good about uh getting people out to fix them but the ac people came right before i was going to leave for my flight and um and this is to st louis i assume uh yeah yeah to st louis and uh they the circuit breaker
箱，嗯，显然在最初安装时没有正确标记，因为空调维修人员不小心关掉了冰箱。哦，不。我们回来时，冰箱里所有的东西都烂透了。所以，我们回来后既没有空调，公寓里还有点臭味。嗯，不是有点臭。是相当臭。事实上，我们俩本应在周日同一时间飞回来。我本打算周日下午 2:30 到达拉瓜迪亚机场，我女朋友大约 3:30 到达。
box in this apartment um was apparently not labeled correctly when they first put it in there because the AC people accidentally turned off the fridge. Oh, no. And we came back and everything in the fridge was spoiled rotten. So, we came back to no AC and also a slightly stinky apartment. Well, not slightly stinky. It was fairly stinky. And actually, we were both supposed to fly back at the same time on Sunday. I was going to get into LaGuardia at like 2.30 on Sunday and my girlfriend was going to land at like 3.30.
但纽约和佛罗里达都有雷暴。所以，她最终在机场待了五六个小时，因为一直说，哦，我们不能起飞，因为坦帕上空有雷暴。然后当坦帕上空晴朗时，纽约又出现了雷暴，他们无法起飞前往纽约。就这样来回折腾了一整天。最后，他们只是说，好吧，大家都去睡觉吧。我们明天早上再飞。事后看来，发生这种事是好事，因为如果我们同时到家，而她不得不闻到我闻到的味道，她肯定会很不高兴，而且她再也不会用那个冰箱了，我们
But there were thunderstorms in New York and in Florida. And so, she ended up being at the airport for like five or six hours on Sunday because it kept being like, oh, we can't leave because there's thunderstorm over Tampa. And then when it was clear over Tampa, there would be a thunderstorm in New York and they wouldn't be able to leave and get to New York. And then it just like flipped back and forth all day. And then eventually, they were just like, all right, everybody go to sleep. We're going to fly out the next morning. And in hindsight, it was good that this happened because if we had both arrived home at the same time and she had had to uh uh smell what i smelled she would not have been happy and she would have never used that fridge again we would
就不得不买个新冰箱了。嗯，那仍然是一种可能性，我们可能永远无法去除冰箱里的异味。接着是一系列不幸事件，昨天我尝试升级在圣克拉拉工作站上的 CMake。Debian 想要安装一个新的 LibC，而 LibC 想要运行这个用户合并程序。长话短说，我的工作站完全瘫痪了。嗯，我的，嗯，我的动态链接器，这是每个程序运行所必需的东西，不知怎么被覆盖了。那个，指向它的符号链接被覆盖了，然后我就什么也运行不了了。我本可以自己走出这个困境，因为我仍然可以通过 SSH 会话连接到机器，但我不是以 root 用户身份登录的。所以我最终可以调用
have just had to buy a new fridge uh that's that's still that is still a possibility that we may never get the ick out of the fridge. And then continuing the series of unfortunate events, I tried to upgrade CMake on my workstation, which is in Santa Clara yesterday. And Debian wanted to install a new LibC, and LibC wanted to run this user merge thing. And long story short, my workstation is like completely bricked. Um, my, uh, my dynamic linker, which is a thing that every program needs to run, uh, somehow got overwritten. The, like the SIM link to it got, got overwritten and The symlink to it got overwritten. And then I couldn't run anything. And I could have gotten myself out of this hole because I still had an SSH session into the machine, but I was not SSH'd in as root. So I eventually could invoke the
创建我恢复系统所需的符号链接的命令。但我没有 root 权限，而我需要它才能创建那个符号链接。所以我有一位非常勤奋的同事，他能够走到系统前，通过实时启动盘，即实时 USB 启动并创建了符号链接。但当他实时启动时，他说，你知道，这台机器运行得非常热。我想你的水冷散热器坏了。于是，他去 IT 部门试图找一个水冷散热器，但他们没有新的。最后，他去拆了另一台系统，终于找到了一个能在我系统上工作的散热器，让我的系统恢复了运行。嗯，我仍然无法真正进入它，它现在虽然启动并运行了，但似乎还有其他问题，所以这周真不是我的周，伙计。
command that would create the symlink I needed to restore the system. But I didn't have root access and I needed it to be able to create that symlink. And so I had a very diligent co-worker who was able to go over to the system and live boot it, a live USB and create the symlink. But as he's live booting, he's like, you know, this machine's running like really hot. I think your water cooler is dead. So, then he goes to IG to try to find a water cooler and they don't have a new cooler. So, then eventually he goes and like cannibalizes another system, finally finds a cooler that's going to work for my system, gets my system back up um i still can't actually get into it uh it is like up and running now but there seems to be some other issue so it's just not been my week man
似乎有一个主题：空调、冰箱和冷却系统。是的，我甚至没往那方面想。是的。所有与温度有关的东西都坏了。那么你搬了多少了？完全搬进去了吗？我是说，我们所有的东西都在这儿了。我是说，
there seems to be a theme ac fridge and cooling system yeah i didn't even think about that. Yeah. Everything to do with temperature is broken. So what percentage are you moved? Are you fully moved in? I mean, all of our stuff is here. I mean,
我的房间已经整理好了。这是网络摄像头吗？你能把它拿起来转一圈吗？它固定在这里。不过，我有控制权，所以我不能那样做。这是第二间卧室，也就是我的办公室。
my room is unpacked by my room. Is this a webcam? Can you pick it up and rotate it around? It is attached here. However, I do have controls, so I can't do that. This is the second bedroom, which is where my office is.
你可以看到它还没有完全整理好。哦，它确实能 360 度旋转。不，也许它不能 360 度旋转。它叫 Insta360，所以我以为它能转一圈，但我想它能提供 360 度的视野，但实际上并不能完全旋转一圈，这倒也说得通。嗯，这是个新相机吗？我从来没见过你处于如此，嗯，如此高保真，或者说，你以前从来没法旋转旧相机，没法设置对比度。而且无论怎么摆放相机，要么我的脸会很暗，要么就会严重背光。
You can see it's not fully unpacked. Oh, and it does do 360. No, maybe it doesn't go 360. It's called the Insta360, so i would have assumed it would go all the way around but i guess it gives you 360 degrees but does not actually rotate all the way around which kind of makes sense um is this a new a new camera i've never i've never seen you in such uh in such high fidelity slash uh you've never been able to spin the old camera, there was no way to set the contrast. And there was no positioning of the camera where either my face would be very dark or it would be very backlit.
所以我需要买一个能控制对比度的东西。于是我买了它。它还有一些人工智能和追踪功能。然后，哦，最令人兴奋的是这栋楼没有健身房，我以此为理由安装了这个大家伙，一台 Bowflex MAX 10，MAX 16 椭圆机兼楼梯机，非常棒，远比我旧楼里的椭圆机好。我昨晚锻炼得非常充分，嗯，这很不错，因为这样如果你在开会，我一直，我一直想要这种功能，如果你在
And so I needed to get something where I had contrast control. And so I got this thing. It also has some AI and tracking. And then, oh, the most exciting thing is this building doesn't have a gym, which I was able to use as justification to put in this bad boy, a Bowflex MAX 10, MAX 16 elliptical slash uh stair machine um which is very good far better than the ellipticals in my old building i got quite the workout last night and um that's quite nice because then if you're in a meeting i've always i've always kind of wanted that like if you're in a
开会，你基本上可以在电脑前做做楼梯运动。这确实是很大一部分动力，因为它为我解锁了额外两到三个小时的会议时间，因为在健身房开会很难，因为那样很不礼貌。所以，嗯，是的，我的意思是，我仍然喜欢骑自行车出去骑行，但是，嗯，特别是在冬天，这东西对于多任务处理来说将是救命稻草。所以如果我在会议期间气喘吁吁，那很可能是因为我在用这个东西。我认为在 2024 年，这完全是合理的，而且几乎应该受到鼓励。我相信有一些研究表明运动可以提升大脑活动和，你知道，精神专注度。
meeting you can just like you know do some stairs while you're right at your computer basically it was a big part of the motivation is that this unlocks like an extra two to three hours of meetings for me because it's hard to take meetings in the gym because it would be rude so um yeah i mean i still like to get out on my bike and actually like go out and ride um but uh especially during the winter this thing's going to be clutch for for multitasking so if i'm out of breath during a meeting it's probably because i'm i'm on this thing i think it's an entire in like in 2024 it's an entirely reasonable and like it should be encouraged almost i'm sure there's some study out there that shows exercise elevates brain activity and you know mental focus
而且，嗯，我以前听过会议上的人说，他们听起来肯定是在散步或者在做运动，但这不是史蒂夫·乔布斯过去常做的事吗？你知道，就像，哦，我们要开个会，走吧，我们出门去库比蒂诺散散步。而且，嗯，我认为这很好，你知道，我认为我们应该鼓励运动，特别是像这么多会议，90% 的参与者什么都没说，对吧？所以如果你有一台固定自行车或椭圆机，甚至像我听说过的那种小型步行跑步机，就是你开始走，然后传送带就开始移动，是的，那种东西。这确实很难，因为我喜欢在几乎我主持的每一个会议上做记录，
and uh i've heard i've heard people on meetings before that they definitely sound like they're on a walk or they're doing some exercise but like isn't that that's what steve jobs used to do you know it's like oh we're doing a meeting let's go we're out the door we're going for a walk around cupertino and uh i think it's good you know i think we should we should be encouraging exercise especially like so many meetings like 90 of the participants aren't saying anything right so if you've got a stationary bike or a elliptical or even like a i've heard of these little like walking like un-electric walking treadmills that are just like you start walking and then the belt starts moving yeah that kind of stuff it is tough because i like to take minutes in pretty much every meeting
嗯，那些是我能控制日程的会议。所以这确实有点棘手，但也许我会尝试 AI 转录之类的东西。哦，你知道吗？我刚意识到我们应该把这次录音推迟一个小时，因为录完这个，我就要去取我的报时钟了，它会让你发疯的，现在终于修好了。我相信未来会有几百集，嗯，亨利时钟，或者叫它时钟，是的，它会首次亮相。总之，我们有一些事情要聊，我们提到了 ISO C++ 委员会
that i'm running um and those are the meetings that I have the control over the schedule. So it is a little bit tricky, but maybe I'll try AI transcriptions or something like that. Oh, and you know what? I just realized we should have had this recording session an hour later, because right after this, I'm going to pick up my chiming clock it's going to drive you crazy that is now finally repaired i'm sure there's a future several hundred episodes where yeah where henry the clock or is it on the clock yeah he will make his uh debut anyways we got uh got some things to chat about we mentioned the uh iso c++ committee
在圣路易斯的会议，嗯，是的，反射，宝贝。你想回顾一下吗？我们把这一集叫做，嗯，我们会提到搬家，我们不确定，但我们会叫它，你知道，圣路易斯 ISO 委员会会议。你知道，我是一个如此喧闹和鲁莽的角色，如果不包含一些我只是度过了糟糕一周的小内容，那将是一个巨大的错误。就像我被诅咒了一样。我觉得听众应该听到这些。这些都会保留在这一集里。这些都会保留在这一集里。问题是，它会影响这一集的标题吗？这就是我们刚才讨论的，因为我们有点
meeting in um st louis which yeah reflection baby you want to give a recap on uh we'll call this episode it'll be uh we'll move and get mentioned we're not sure but we'll call it you know the st louis iso committee meeting you know i'm such a boisterous and brash character that it would be a huge mistake to not include some of the little content where I'm just having a bad week. Where just like I'm cursed. Like I feel like the listener deserves to hear that. That's all staying in the episode. That's all staying in the episode. The question is, does it impact the title of the episode that's what we were talking about there because we kind of it
需要吸引眼球，对吧？你知道，人们关心委员会会议和 C++ 的进展，然后我们还要简要提到，现在是几号？我相信是 7 月 2 日，距离 20 天，坏消息。其实，也许我们先谈谈这个。坏消息。CPP North 即将举行。坏消息是我要错过你的演讲了，Bryce。因为我从墨西哥的一个单身派对回来，周一下午 2 点才能降落在多伦多。而你的演讲是在——所以你 7 月 21 日我的生日那天不在。我不关心你错过我的演讲。
needs to be clickbaity right you know it's like people care about the committee meetings and the progress of c++ and then we're also going to briefly mention in what is it it's july 2nd i believe in 20 in t minus 20 days bad news Actually, maybe we'll talk about this first. Bad news. CPP North is happening. And the bad news is I'm going to miss your talk, Bryce. Because I don't land back in Toronto from a bachelor party I'm going to be at in Mexico until 2 p.m. on Monday. And your talk is at – So you're not going to be around for July 21st, my birthday. I don't care about you missing my talk.
你错过了我的生日。好吧，你得想办法补偿我。我们不是已经有晚餐计划了吗？我们确实已经有晚餐计划了。我不认为那是为了——好吧，如果是为了周日，是的，坏消息。其实，可能是。让我查查。等等，我们已经预订了吗？
You're missing my birthday. Well, you're going to have to figure out how to make that up to me. Didn't we already have dinner plans or something like that? We do already have dinner plans. I don't think that was for – well, if it was for the Sunday, yes, bad news. Actually, it may have been. Let me check. Wait, we already have reservations?
我很确定。我没意识到。如果我们没预订，我会很惊讶。等等，我们已经预订了吗？我很确定。我没意识到。如果我们没预订，我会很惊讶。我不会感到惊讶。我觉得我应该知道这些预订。我以为我在 Aloe 预订了。但我没在这里看到。我想我们肯定讨论过，因为你，如果我错了请纠正我，是要去尼亚加拉大瀑布还是尼亚加拉湖滨小镇？
Pretty sure. I didn't realize that. I'd be surprised if we didn't. Wait, we already have reservations? Pretty sure. I didn't realize that. I'd be surprised if we didn't. I would be unsurprised. I feel like I would have known about these reservations. I thought I made reservations at Aloe. I don't see it here, though. I think we definitely talked about it because you, correct me if I'm wrong, are going to Niagara Falls or Niagara on the Lake?
不，我们在 7 月 23 日在 Hour 有预订。我们有吗？我们已经去过那里了，伙计。你都去过三次了。你找个别的地方吧。那倒是。待定，我们去哪儿。重点是 CPP North 将在 21 日到 23 日举行，我想是这些日期吗？我们应该把日期搞对。我假设 23 日是周三，对吧？是的，我相信是这样。是的，肯定是周三。21 日到 24 日。
No, we have reservations on July 23rd at hour. We do? We've already been there, man. You've been there like three times. You find another place. That's true. TBD, where we go. point is cpp north is happening 21st to 23rd i think are those the dates we should get these dates right i assume that the 23rd is the wednesday correct yeah i believe so yeah yeah it's got to be the wednesday yeah 21st to 24th
其实不是，这意味着 23 日将是周二。为什么我在看八月？因为我本该那样做的。所以，是的。上面说它从 21 日开始，因为我想 21 日有一个晚间社交活动，人们去领取他们的徽章。当然，还要庆祝 Bryce 的生日。而且，是的。我想也许他们应该把那改名为“领取你的徽章”。其实，它应该是“Bryce 生日和领取徽章庆祝活动”，然后周一到周三是会议举行的时间。
actually no so that means that the 23rd is going to be the Tuesday. Why am I looking at August right? Because I should have done that. So, yeah. It says it starts on the 21st because I think on the 21st there is an evening social where people pick up their badges. And celebrate Bryce's birthday, of course. And, yes. I guess maybe they should just rebrand that to the Pick Up Your Badge. Actually, it should be the Bryce Birthday and Pick up your badge celebration and then the monday to wednesday is when the conference is happening
不需要礼物，你随时可以给我现金。哦，Bryce，是的，我们提到这个的原因是我们俩都会去。去年我不得不让 Ben Dean 代替你，今年你不会被取代，因为你会去。
gifts are not required you can always just bring me cash oh bryce and yes the reason we bring it up is because we're both going to be there last year I had to replace you with Ben Dean this year you will not be replaced as you will be there
Ben Dean 会去，我们可能会和他聊聊，他有演讲，你也有演讲。总之，我们最后会回到 CPP North，给我们更新一下 ISO 委员会会议的情况。嗯，我想有两件大事。首先是我们投票将 C++ 异步框架 Senders 纳入了 C++26。其次是我们设计批准了 C++26 的反射功能。这两项都是相当大的功能。
Ben Dean will be there we'll probably talk to him he's got to talk you've got to talk anyways we'll circle back to CBP North at the end give us the update about the ISO committee meeting. Well, two big things, I guess. First is that we voted senders the C++ asynchronous framework into C++26. And the second is that we design approved reflection for C++26. And both those are pretty big features.
我的意思是，我认为反射是一个更大的事情。反射是一个巨大的、改变游戏规则的功能。Herb 说他认为这将是自 C++98 以来对 C++ 影响最大的功能。我认为这很公平。我认为它可能与另外几个功能竞争，你知道，模块在某种程度上影响了语言，不仅仅是
I mean, I think reflection is a much bigger deal. Reflection is a huge game-changing feature. Herb said that he thinks it's going to have the biggest impact on C++ of any feature since C++98. I think that's probably fair I think it may compete with a couple others you know modules impacts the language in ways outside
源代码，对吧？它影响了我们构建代码的方式，而且距离我们看到模块的影响还需要几年时间。距离我们看到模块的影响还需要几年时间。还需要几年？我想是的，因为生态系统采用新事物需要时间。你可以争辩说，也许 C++11 的某些东西产生了同样大的影响。我不知道。
of just the source code right it impacts how we structure code and it's going to still be years before we sort of see the impact of modules but it's still going to be years before we see the impact of modules. It's still going to be years? I think so, because it takes a while for the ecosystem to adopt things. You could argue that maybe some set of C++11 things have had as big of an impact. I don't know.
也许有人会争辩说是移动语义。我甚至不确定我会走那么远。Constexpr 也许。Constexpr 可能是那个东西，因为它解锁了编译时元编程的整个新领域。但你以前也能做那种事。反射确实非常具有颠覆性。它解锁了以前不可能实现的各种功能，而且它还给了我们进化语言的新方法。我们以前必须作为语言功能构建的东西，现在可以作为库功能构建了。
Maybe one could argue move semantics. I'm not even sure I would go that far. Constexpr maybe. Constexpr may be the thing because it unlocks this whole new field of compile time metaprogramming. But you could kind of do that before. Reflection is really very game-changing. It unlocks a variety of things that weren't previously possible, but also it gives us new ways to evolve the language. Things that we previously had to build as library features, we could build as... Or the things we previously had to build as language features, we can now build as library features.
是的，Spaceship 不是其中之一吗？是的，本可以做到。嗯，Spaceship 有一个语法组件，对吧？就像有一个新的运算符。但如果你只是决定把它称为，你知道，只是把它称为一个成员函数，你知道，随便选一个协议名称，你知道，就像调用 compare，那么你本可以完成剩下的部分。是的，是的。
Yeah, isn't Spaceship one of those? Yeah, could have done. Well, Spaceship had a syntactic component, right? Like there was a new operator. But if you had just decided to call it like a, you know, just to call it like a member function, you know, just pick some protocol name, you know just to call it like a member function you know just pick some some protocol name you know like uh like call like compare um then you could have done the rest yeah yeah
所以，是的，这是一件大事。我非常有信心它到时候会进入标准。嗯，我们的同事 Andre Alexandrescu 实际上一直在研究一些后续工作，帮助推动其中的注入部分。你如何把东西放回去？你如何基于反射生成新东西？我们如何生成新函数？我们如何包装函数、成员和类？你如何操作你已经反射的东西？我们确定的模型是这种叫做标记序列的东西。所以我们探索了几种不同的方法。我们探索了一种规范方法，你可以通过调用 define class 来定义一个新函数或类型，然后传入一个描述类中所有成员、类型等的结构体。我们也研究了函数的情况，你定义签名等等。但我们想要的一个属性是，我们希望当你编写注入代码时，当你编写将在编译时生成的新代码时，我们希望它看起来像 C++ 代码。而这种规范方法看起来并不太像 C++ 代码，
um so yeah it's a big deal i'm i'm very confident it'll get in at this point um my uh our colleague actually andre alexandrsku has been been working on some follow-on things, helping to drive some of the injection part of it. How do you put things back in? How do you generate new stuff based on reflection? How do we generate new functions? How do we like wrap functions and members and classes? And how do you manipulate the things that you've reflected? And the model that we've settled upon is this thing called token sequences. So there's a couple different approaches we explored. We explored a spec approach where you could define a new function or type by – you'd call define class and then you'd pass in this struct that describes all the members of the class and the types and stuff like that. And we looked into that too for functions where you define the signature and whatnot. But one of the properties we wanted is that we wanted when you're writing the injective code, when you're writing new code that's going to be generated at compile time, we wanted it to look like C++ code. And this spec approach doesn't really look like C++ code,
而且它很快就会变得非常冗长。这种方法有几种不同的变体。有一种我认为属于大致相同的范畴，但更多是基于 AST 的，你就像以非常相似的方式操作 AST，你是在以编程方式进行。我认为它有所有相同的缺点，但它还有一个额外的缺点，即以这种方式暴露 AST 使得进化语言变得更加困难。因为，你知道，例如，如果我们标准化了，那么表达式的 AST 节点在类型上可能会改变。它们可能不再是语句节点。因此，这可能会限制我们未来进化语言的能力。然后我们还研究了一种基于字符串的操作方法，
and it gets very verbose very fast. And there's a couple different variations of that approach. There's one that's I think it's sort of the same broad category, but it's more AST based where you're like manipulating the AST in a very similar way where you're sort of doing it programmatically. And I think it had all of the same downsides, but it also had the additional downside that exposing up the AST in that way makes it harder to evolve the language. Because like, you know, for example, if we have our standardized then the AST nodes for expressions might change in type. They might not be statement nodes. And so it might limit how we'd be able to evolve the language going forward. And then we also looked at a string-based manipulation approach,
注入代码的方式就是给它一个字符串，说，这是一些 C++ 代码字符串，把这个注入到程序中。但有人担心这并不是真正稳健的，它可能会很脆弱，
where the way you injected code is you just gave it a string and said, here's some string of C++ stuff inject this into the program but there were some concerns that that's not really not going to really be robust, that it could be brittle
诊断信息可能不会很好，它不会是卫生的，而且你在字符串中的代码下不会得到任何语法高亮，这会有点遗憾。但那是某种程度上的第二选择。然后标记序列方法是，与其操作字符串，不如操作这些标记序列。这是几乎所有编译器都携带的信息。
that diagnostics could be not great that it would sort of not be hygienic and you wouldn't get any syntax highlighting underneath that code in the string, which would be a little unfortunate. But that was sort of kind of the runner-up approach. And then the token sequence approach is that instead of manipulating strings, you'd manipulate these sequences of tokens. And this is sort of information that pretty much all the compilers carry around.
所以这会更干净一些。我们甚至设想可以在此基础上构建一个卫生的宏设施。所以在某些方面，它类似于，我认为它在某种程度上类似于 Rust 宏及其工作方式，这种标记序列的东西。所以不清楚我们是否会在 C++26 中看到标记序列。它不是已批准的核心反射提案的一部分。甚至不清楚我们在 C++26 中会看到多少注入功能，但我们肯定还在研究它，而且我们还有相当多的时间。所以我们非常希望我们能完成一些后续工作。我们还在这次会议上加入了 in-place vector，
And so this would be a little bit cleaner. And we even imagined that we could build a hygienic macro facility on top of this. So in some ways, it's similar to, I think it's somewhat similar to Rust macros and how they work, this token sequence stuff. So not clear whether we'll see token sequences in C++26. It's not part of the core reflection proposal that's been approved. And it's not even clear how much of injection we'll see in C++26, but we're definitely still working on it, and we've still got a good bit of time. So we're pretty hopeful that we're going to get some of this follow-on work done. We also landed in-place vector at this meeting,
这是一个具有固定容量的向量，你可以给它一个在栈上或静态分配的内存块，然后它可以在该容量内动态增长。它永远不会动态分配内存，但它可以在该固定容量内增加大小。所以，这是我们一直在研究的东西。Std-simd 提案取得了很大进展。我们很可能会在下次会议上看到它被推进到 C++26。这些是我想我们可以期待 26 版本的两个大库功能，即 SIMD 和 senders/receivers。我知道这非常令人兴奋，因为
which is a vector which has a fixed capacity where you can just give it a block of memory that's on the stack or statically allocated, and then it can grow dynamically within that capacity. It'll never dynamically allocate memory, but it can grow in its size within that fixed capacity. So, that's been something we've been working on for a while. The std-cimd proposals made a lot of progress. We're going to likely see that get advanced into C++ 26 at the next meeting. Those are sort of the two big library features that I think we can expect for 26 are going to be SIMD and senders and receivers. I know that that's pretty exciting because
Std Execution 和反射显然都很重要。我知道，我不记得是谁的计划了，但有一些 C++26 的大型计划。模式匹配在那个列表上。关于模式匹配有什么更新吗？据我所知没有。它，是的，它很可能上周被讨论过。我不知道。是的。
std execution and reflection are obviously both big. I know that I so that's pretty exciting because Stead Execution and Reflection are obviously both big. I know that, I can't remember whose plan it was, but there's some C++26, you know, large plan. Pattern matching was on that list. Is there any update on pattern matching or no? Not that I'm aware of. It, yeah, it could well have been discussed last week. I don't know. Yeah.
有很多空间。等等，我们花了一些时间讨论平凡重定位和契约。这是另一个大讨论。我不认为契约会进入 C++26。嗯，我想它可能会进入 TS 或类似的东西。那里还有很多悬而未决的问题。这是一个有趣的更新，
There's a lot of, there's a lot of room. So wait, there was some, some time we spent talking about trivial relocation, um, and a contract. It's been another big discussion. I do not think contracts will make it into C++ 26. Um, I think it's going to probably go to a TS or something. There's still a lot of, a lot of open questions there. That's an interesting update
因为我想我最后一次听说契约是因为，Teamer 不是 CppCast 的联合主持人吗？他是，我不认为他是，他是主席还是副主席？如果他不是主席或副主席，他是该工作组的常客之一，我想他在 CppCast 的剧集中提到它时一直很乐观，认为它会进入 C++26，但我只是认为这不太可能，因为设计上仍然存在很多不确定性，而且它几乎需要在下次会议或再下一次会议上通过，但实际上它需要在下次会议前解决。嗯，在哪里
because I think the last thing I heard about contracts because I think, doesn't Teamer co-host of CppCast? He's, I don't think he's, is he the chair or vice chair think he's is he the chair or vice chair if he's not the chair or vice chair he's one of the uh regular attendees of that working group and i think he's been pretty hopeful on the episodes of cpp cast when he mentions it that it'll uh get in for c++ 26 but i i i just think it's unlikely because there's still a lot of uncertainty about the design and it would pretty much need to make it at the next meeting or maybe the meeting after that but really it would need to it'd need to be settled by the next meeting um where's the
下次会议是在波兰的弗罗茨瓦夫。谁主办？我相信是诺基亚。我的波兰女朋友和我母亲都会去。那很令人兴奋。什么时候？那是九月？十一月。十一月。
next meeting is in pol Poland in Wroclaw. Who's hosting that? Nokia, I believe. And my Polish girlfriend and my mother will both be there. That's exciting. When is it? That's September? November. November.
为什么那么远？我以为有三次会议。确实有，但总是二月、三月、初夏，然后是十一月。是在弗罗茨瓦夫还是华沙？是在弗罗茨瓦夫。好的。那么它会和 Code Dive 会议重合吗？是的。Code Dive 会议就在华沙的一周后。不幸的是，我不认为我今年能去 CodeDive，
Why so far? I thought there was three meetings. There are, but it's always February, March, early summer, and then November. And is it in Wroclaw or is it in Warsaw? It's in Wroclaw. Okay. So is it going to be coinciding with the Code Dive conference? It is. The Code Dive conference is like the week after in Warsaw. I don't think I'll actually be able to go to CodeDive this year, unfortunately,
因为我们要去 Core C++。所以我想我们会在 25 日从华沙飞走，因为 Core C++ 在 26 日开始。而 CodeDive 在 25 日。所以我不能确定它是否行得通。你也要去 Meeting C++ 吗？是的，我要去。柏林那个？
because we're going to Core C++. And so we'll be flying from Warsaw, I think, on the 25th, because Core C++ starts on the 26th. And CodeDive is on the 25th. So I'm not certain if it's going to work out. Are you going to meeting C++ as well? I am, yeah. The one in Berlin?
我要去 Meeting C++，我还要进行一点德国 C++ 用户组、HPC 中心和喜欢 GPU 的人们的巡回访问。不错。你十一月要做的演讲是什么？还是我原来的演讲，Think Parallel 演讲。我可能会给出一个稍微更新的版本，重点关注一些与我目前给出的版本中扫描算法不同的算法。所以我可能会谈谈一些归约算法。
I'm going to meeting C++, and I'm doing a little bit of a tour of German C++ user groups and HPC centers and people who like GPUs. Nice. What's the talks that you're going to be giving in November? It's going to be my same talk, the Think Parallel talk. I'm probably going to give a slightly updated version of it that focuses on some different algorithms than the scan algorithms that have been in the versions that I've given thus far. So I may talk about some reduction algorithms.
好的。是的，然后我想那圆满的一半，谁知道圆的哪一部分把我们带回了 CPP North，你要讲什么？我要讲我的 Think Parallel scans 演讲。好的，因为我本来想说我已经看到 ACCU 的演讲开始在线发布了，但我还没看到你的，因为我一直在等
Okay. Yeah. And then I guess that full circle half a circle, who knows what portion of a circle brings us back to CPP North which are you giving me I'm giving my think parallel scans talk okay, because I was going to say I've seen the ACCU talks start to come out online I have not seen yours yet because i've been waiting to
更新链接，从我们把它包含在节目笔记中的那一集开始，我想现在我必须再次把它包含在节目笔记中，但这将是一个未链接的链接，因为录音至少截至昨天或两天前还没有出来，但你会做同样的演讲，所以我想，这是个好消息。我知道他们正在努力，因为他们问我是否可以给它一个更长的标题，因为 Think Parallel 不是一个很好的 SEO 标题，所以他们想要 YouTube 视频有一个更长的标题。是的，这是一个有趣的，你对此有什么想法？因为我想我去年在 CPP North 的演讲标题是
update the link from whatever episode we included that in the show notes and i guess now i have to include it again in this show notes uh but it'll be a an unlinked link because the the recording at least as of yesterday or two days ago um is not out yet but you'll be giving that same talk so i guess uh it's good news i know they're i know they're working on it because they asked me if they could give it a longer title because think parallel is not a very good title for seo and so they wanted they wanted the youtube video to have a longer title yeah that's an interesting what are your thoughts on that because i think my cpp north talk from last year its title was
Composition Intuition，但他们最终在 YouTube 视频中把它重命名为，比如，Function Composition。我告诉他们，他们问是否可以重命名，我告诉他们我更喜欢不重命名，因为我不喜欢名字里有副标题的演讲。他们想用 Think Parallel，冒号，某某某。我从来不喜欢那样。我认为我很乐意在描述中放入一些关键词。如果人们想找到它，他们会找到的，你知道，我相信 YouTube 算法，我是这么说的，你知道。是的，我会说，我会说，天哪，我
composition intuition but they ended up renaming it at least in the youtube video like uh function composition in i i i told them i they asked whether they could rename it and i told them that i would prefer not to because i dislike dislike talks that have a subtitle in the name. They wanted to do Think Parallel, colon, something, something, something. And I just am never a fan of that. And I think I'm happy to have some keywords put in the description. And people will find it if they're gonna find it you know i i trust the youtube algorithm is what i'm saying you know yeah i will say i will say oh my god i
嗯，这里有个小插曲，各位，我喜欢 YouTube 推荐算法。无论如何，各位，如果你是听众，或者你是 YouTube 算法开发人员的朋友，下次见到他们握个手。真的，我想大概有 37 次观看，Sean Parent 在纽约 C++ 的聚会演讲，我其实不知道。也许我订阅了，这就是原因。但它不在我的订阅面板里。它在我的主页上，和我们在三月份看到的 Chains 演讲在一起。它有 37 次观看，YouTube 把那个演讲推荐给了我。就像，走吧。这是最深奥的东西。你认为 YouTube 的推荐算法会进行内容分析吗？你认为他们仅仅基于标题和
well a little tangent here just a small tangent folks i love the youtube recommendation algorithm whatever folks if you're a listener or you're friends of someone that works on the YouTube algorithm, give them a handshake next time. Literally with like, I think it was 37 views, the Sean Parent meetup talk from New York C++, which I actually don't know. Maybe I am subscribed and that's why. But it was not in my subscription pane. It was on my homepage with the chains talk that we saw back in March. It had 37 views and YouTube recommended that talk to me. Like, let's go. It's the most esoteric thing. Do you think that YouTube's recommendation algorithm does content analysis? Do you think that they recommend solely based on title and
描述进行推荐吗？还是你认为他们……不，他们这样做是因为，我会说它肯定会进行内容分析的原因是，当你现在进行谷歌搜索时，有时它会给你 YouTube 视频中的时间戳。它会说，比如第 3 分 37 秒讨论了，如果你说如何做某事，它会给你一个 YouTube 视频，然后……YouTube 视频，你现在可以在 YouTube 视频中包含章节，所以你可以说，比如第 0 分钟到第 1 分钟是介绍，第 1 分钟到第 3 分钟是，你知道，其他主题。我不知道你是否在 YouTube 视频上见过那个，
description? Or do you think that they... No, they do it because the reason I would say that it definitely does content analysis is because when you do a Google search these days, sometimes it'll give you the timestamp within a YouTube video. It'll say like minute 337 discusses like if you say how to do something, it'll give you a YouTube video and then... YouTube videos, you can now include chapters in the youtube video so you can say like minute zero to minute one is the intro minute one to minute three is you know some other topic i don't know if you've ever seen that on a youtube video
但是的，所以可能是那样，但，嗯，但我怀疑它是否也可能只是你附加到 YouTube 视频上的关键词，对吧？嗯，是的，但这不会给你时间戳。但我敢打赌，如果他们现在不做内容分析来推荐，他们很快就会做的。我的意思是，因为他们已经在做 AI 转录了，对吧？是的，是的。他们已经做转录有一段时间了。所以他们有 Javascript 转录。所以那只是文本。
but yeah so it might be that but um but i wonder whether it couldn't just be the keywords too as well that you attach to youtube videos right um yeah but that wouldn't give you the timestamp. But I would bet that if they're not doing content analysis for recommendations now, they will be sometime in the near future. I mean, because they're already doing AI transcription, right? Yes, yes. They've been doing transcripts for a while now. So they have the Javascript transcript. So that's just text.
这对他们来说在排名和推荐中使用成本很低，对吧？就像如果他们已经在做从视频生成文本的事情，这是昂贵的操作，我想，而且他们已经在做了，因为已经有转录的用例了。那么他们已经有了这些数据。他们不妨使用它。他们几乎肯定已经在做诸如情感分析之类的事情，以分析某人是否真的很生气，或者视频中是否有暴力内容，因为他们必须为了内容审核而这样做。比如如果有人上传了一个视频，比如，你知道，犯罪或者
That's pretty low cost for them to use in ranking and recommendations, right? Like if they're already doing the thing that generates text from the video, which is the expensive operation, I would assume, and they're already doing it because there's already a use case for that, transcripts. Then they've already got that data. They may as well use it. They're almost certainly already doing things like sentiment analysis to analyze whether somebody is really angry or there's violence in a video because they have to do that for content moderation right like if someone like uploads a video of like you know like crime or
比如那种东西，或者暴力，他们需要能够检测到它，嗯，这样他们要么可以审核掉它，要么可以给它加上一个，你知道，图形暴力警告。嗯，你知道，那可能是 AI。我的意思是，也许，也许有人只是观看，或者他们可以给它加上一个图形暴力警告。那可能是 AI。我的意思是，也许有人只是观看所有视频。我假设涉及了一些 AI。然后他们还必须为版权侵权进行内容分析。所以他们做了很多事情，如果他们不把，嗯，是的，比如你实际谈论的数据输入到你的，嗯，输入到，嗯，推荐
like like stuff like that or like violence they they need to be able to detect that um so that they can either moderate it away or that they can put a you know graphic violence warning on it um uh you know that's that's probably ai i mean it maybe maybe there's somebody who just watches or that they can put a graphic violence warning on it. That's probably AI. I mean, maybe there's somebody who just watches all the videos. I assume some AI is involved. And then they also have to do content analysis for copyright infringement. So they're doing a lot of stuff i'd be i'd be shocked if they're not feeding um yeah uh like data from from what you're actually talking about into your um into the uh the recommendation
算法中，我会感到震惊。所以也许演讲标题并不重要。不，我绝对认为它很重要。我的意思是，演讲标题和缩略图是我认为最重要的两件事。我认为对于会议演讲来说，它没那么重要。但我认为对于一些病毒式视频，或者只是你试图获得成千上万或数百次观看的视频。我不认为我需要在标题中加入 C++ 这个词。我的意思是，作为演讲标题，你绝对不需要。为了在 YouTube 上优化，我其实不知道。让我放，它会有帮助吗？几乎
algorithm so so maybe the talk title doesn't really matter no i i definitely think it does i mean talk title and thumbnail i, are the two most significant things. I think for a conference talk, it doesn't matter as much. But I think for like some viral video or just some video where you're trying to get thousands or hundreds of views. I don't think I need to put the word C++ into the title. I mean, as a talk title, you definitely don't. For optimizing on YouTube, I actually don't know. Let me put it would it help almost
肯定会有帮助。你认为 YouTube 的算法知道我的演讲是关于 C++ 的吗，即使我不说？是的，是的，是的。我想它知道。我想它有一些智能。我想它对转录本做了一些分析。我想它做了一些排名，我想它做了一些分析，我想它做了一些排名，而且我认为它知道这是关于 C++ 的事情。如果有人搜索 C++，你知道，并行编程，我的演讲就会出现。是的，就像，如果，是的，完全正确。就像我肯定在我的演讲标题中放入 Code Report 而不是我的真实姓名，因为这就是我在 YouTube 上出名的原因，那会有帮助，但我不会那样做。虽然实际上，我见过一个会议确实这样做了，他们放了我的名字，然后把我的句柄放在旁边。但总之，演讲的名字，
certainly it would help do i think that youtube that youtube's algorithm knows that my talk is about c++ even without me yes yes yes yeah i think it does i think it's got some smarts there i think it's done some analysis on the transcripts i think it's done some rankings there i think it's done some analysis under transcripts i think it's done some rankings and i think it knows this is a thing about c++ and if somebody searches for c++ you know parallel programming that my talk will come up yeah like if yeah exactly like i'm sure putting code report in my talk title instead of my actual name because that's what i'm known by on youtube that would help but i'm not going to do that. Although actually, I've seen that one conference actually did, they put my name and then they put my handle next to it. But anyways, the name of the talk,
他们把 Composition Intuition 改成了 Function Composition in Programming Languages。那是个好决定吗？我的意思是，它是 CPP North YouTube 频道上前五名的演讲之一。所以我不知道。也许他们确实知道自己在做什么。谁知道呢？我，从一个，怎么说呢，比如纯粹主义的角度来看，你知道，它让我感到不安，因为那不是演讲的名字。你知道，演讲的名字是 Composition Intuition。
they switched composition intuition to function composition in programming languages. Was that a good decision? I mean, it is one of the top five talks on the YouTube channel, the CPV North YouTube channel. So I don't know. Maybe they do know what they're doing. Who knows? I, from a, what's the word, like a purity point of view, you know, it upsets me that like it's not the name of the talk. You know, it's the name of the talk is composition intuition.
它和我的另一个演讲 Algorithm Intuition 相匹配。所以改变 YouTube 上的标题，你知道。所以我想要更深入地研究一下。Algorithm Intuition。所以改变 YouTube 上的标题，你知道，我们在做什么？我想要更深入地研究一下。我想要思考处理 YouTube 视频中昂贵的计算工作负载是什么。所以生成转录本并不是那么糟糕。我之所以这么说，是因为音频数据比视频数据小得多，对吧？你有这个音频数据。我所知道的关于音频处理的一切就是有很多傅里叶变换。所以，我假设他们生成转录本的方式是他们获取了
And it matches my other talk, algorithm intuition. So to change the title in the YouTube thing, you know. So I want to dig into this a little bit more. algorithm intuition. So to change the title in the YouTube thing, you know, what are we doing? I want to dig into this a little bit more. I want to think about what are the expensive compute workloads in processing a YouTube video. So generating the transcript isn't that bad. And I say that because audio data is substantially smaller than video data, right? You've got this audio data. All I know about audio processing is there's a lot of Fourier transforms. So, I assume that the way that they generate the transcript is that they take the
这与我的另一场演讲“算法直觉”相呼应。所以为了更改YouTube上的标题，你知道的。我想深入探讨一下这一点。算法直觉。所以为了更改YouTube上的标题，你知道的，我们在做什么？我想深入探讨一下这一点。我想思考一下处理YouTube视频时，哪些是昂贵的计算工作负载。生成转录内容其实并不算太难。我之所以这么说，是因为音频数据比视频数据小得多，对吧？你拥有这些音频数据。关于音频处理，我只知道其中涉及大量的傅里叶变换。所以，我推测他们生成转录内容的方式是，他们获取
audio data, something, something Fourier, and some AI and neural nets these days, and then it produces words out of it. Things that are going to be more expensive, I would imagine, are doing things like OCR, like recognizing text that's on the video content, and also doing things like object detection. I don't know whether they have a thing that searches for copyrighted logos or stuff like that, like copyrighted images or things of that nature. But I would presume that there's something like that. But like, if you have like a, you know, a 30 minute YouTube video at like 4k and 60 FPS, and you want to search through like every frame of that video to see if there's any of a wide range of things that may be in that video you know a logo or you know uh some graphic content
音频数据，某种傅里叶变换，还有如今的一些人工智能和神经网络，然后从中生成文字。我想，成本更高的应该是像OCR这样的事情，比如识别视频内容中的文字，以及进行物体检测。我不知道他们是否有搜索版权标志或类似东西的工具，比如版权图片或类似性质的东西。但我推测应该有类似的功能。但是，如果你有一个30分钟的4K 60帧YouTube视频，并且你想搜索该视频的每一帧，看看视频中是否存在各种各样的东西，比如标志，或者一些图形内容，
um like that's that's got to be pretty expensive right you know yeah i have no idea but i would imagine that they have some kind of like similar to like, what do they call it like a Monte Carlo tree search. If you're familiar with the MCTS, where it's like, they choose that was like the algorithm underpinning AlphaGo and AlphaZero. Actually, I'm not sure about AlphaZero, but definitely AlphaGo is that instead of exploring all possible paths, they would do a couple iterations, figure out the best options, and then continue to explore those. So every single few iterations, they would prune for the top ones and then keep going. So I imagine they have some similar filtering mechanism where they've got some relatively inexpensive way of checking, does this pass all of these things?
嗯，那肯定相当昂贵，对吧？是的，我不知道，但我猜他们可能有一种类似于蒙特卡洛树搜索的东西。如果你熟悉MCTS，它就是支撑AlphaGo和AlphaZero的算法。其实我不确定AlphaZero，但AlphaGo肯定是这样，与其探索所有可能的路径，不如进行几次迭代，找出最佳选项，然后继续探索这些选项。所以每隔几次迭代，他们就会剪枝掉非顶部的选项，然后继续进行。所以我猜他们有类似的过滤机制，通过某种相对廉价的方式来检查，这是否通过了所有这些测试？
And then it narrows it down to the five percent of videos that look suspect and then each step they do the five percent of frames right like you know they could take that 4k video they could down sample it to like a very low resolution and then they could do an initial pass to see like you know okay which which parts of this do we think are sketchy and maybe need to, you know, to be analyzed more? Yeah. Yeah. I imagine it's something like that. I would also assume that, like, they profile channels, especially ones with a lot of subscribers, and those ones immediately they get hit with the full so if you've if you've
然后将其缩小到看起来可疑的5%的视频，并且每一步他们都处理那5%的帧，对吧？比如他们可以获取那个4K视频，将其降采样到非常低的分辨率，然后进行初步筛选，看看哪些部分是我们认为可疑的，可能需要进一步分析的？是的，是的。我想大概就是这样。我还假设他们会对频道进行画像，特别是那些订阅者很多的频道，这些频道会立即受到全面的检查，所以如果你有
got a million plus or you know even half a million plus subscribers and especially if you have a history of posting videos with questionable content you immediately get hit with you know all of the uh all the checking versus like the almost guaranteed the hardest things to check for are these new youtube channels that are brand new and don't have any likes, you know, for, for my channel, I'm sure that they, you know, they don't actually check a lot of, they, they do a couple of like, Oh, verification, verification, but like all my stuff is just programming content. So as long as they can verify that it's, Oh, it's another programming content video, you know, it goes down some separate tier and gets a green
超过一百万，或者甚至超过五十万的订阅者，特别是如果你有发布可疑内容的历史，你就会立即受到所有检查的打击。相比之下，几乎可以肯定的是，最难检查的是那些全新的YouTube频道，它们没有任何点赞。你知道，对于我的频道，我敢肯定他们实际上并没有检查很多，他们只是做了一些验证，但我的所有内容都只是编程内容。所以只要他们能验证这是另一个编程内容视频，它就会进入一个单独的层级并获得绿色
check mark, whereas some other bigger YouTubers that are covering like news or something like that and potentially are going to be violating some um you know code of conduct thing or it's going to get put some label on it those immediately are going to be you know put through some other pipeline i imagine there's a bunch of pipelines and it's not just like, oh, we treat every video equal. Like that seems like it would be a recipe for false positives or. Yeah. Yeah. No, no. I mean.
勾选标记，而其他一些涵盖新闻之类内容的大型YouTuber，如果可能违反了某些行为准则，或者会被贴上某种标签，那么这些视频会立即被放入另一个处理流程中。我想有很多处理流程，不仅仅是“我们平等对待每个视频”。这似乎会导致很多误报。是的，是的。不，不。我的意思是。
But what you're saying makes sense. And it makes sense that they would use the history of a channel. And what you just said about like categorization, I bet that that plays into it too. I bet one of the first things that they do is that they have some relatively cheap pass that, um, that categorizes what kind of video it is. Um, and like, if it's,
但你说的很有道理。他们利用频道的历史记录是有道理的。关于分类，我敢打赌这也起到了作用。我敢打赌他们做的第一件事就是进行某种相对廉价的初步筛选，对视频的类型进行分类。而且，如果是，
if it's a video about, you know, news or something, um, or like current events that maybe they run some different set of filters or like if it's, if it's about politics, you know, they run some other set of filters. like if it's if it's about politics you know they run some other set of filters yeah already you have to you don't have to but it helps if you do and actually you might have to because i i actually don't know uh you have to you there's a combo box for specifying what category of video it is so all of mine are
如果这是一个关于新闻或时事之类的视频，也许他们会运行一套不同的过滤器，或者如果它是关于政治的，他们会运行另一套过滤器。如果它是关于政治的，他们会运行另一套过滤器。是的，你必须这样做，或者说不一定非要这样做，但这样做会有帮助。实际上你可能必须这样做，因为我真的不知道。你有一个组合框来指定视频的类别，所以我的所有视频都是
like education or technology or something like that. But they definitely have like new sports. I imagine sports is like a pretty low one, right? Like TSN has a YouTube channel or ESPN has a YouTube channel. They're always uploading their, you know, sports highlights. They probably get that stuff green checkmarked immediately. And like the biggest problem is copycat channels that are illegally posting copyrighted videos. Yeah, I don't know. I think sports actually is probably the more intense ones.
教育或技术之类的。但他们肯定有新闻、体育之类的分类。我想体育类应该是一个门槛比较低的，对吧？比如TSN有一个YouTube频道，或者ESPN有一个YouTube频道。他们总是上传他们的体育集锦。他们可能立即就能获得绿色勾选标记。最大的问题是那些非法发布版权视频的模仿频道。是的，我不知道。我认为体育类可能实际上是更严格的。
Cause like all of the, cause sports broadcasting is like pretty strict on who gets to broadcast what, like I, every, every tennis grand slam, my girlfriend and I go through the same song and dance of figuring out like, where can she actually watch,
因为体育广播对于谁能广播什么内容非常严格。比如，每一个网球大满贯赛事，我和我女朋友都要经历同样的折腾，去弄清楚她到底能在哪里观看，
you know, Wimbledon or the French open. and it's because you know they they're not just like available to to stream for free um there's like a ton of people who stream like live commentary of them but don't show the video like I'm I'm sure that sports is is actually a a a tricky one um I bet I bet like the ones that are um i don't i don't know what like the easy ones would be there's there's like a lot there's a lot of things to think about there uh because there's like so much there's you know it's not just like recommendation that they got to do but they also have to tackle this whole like content moderation space and like that gets just real complicated
温布尔登网球赛或法国网球公开赛。这是因为它们不仅仅是免费流媒体播放的。有很多人直播比赛的评论，但不显示视频。我敢肯定体育类实际上是一个棘手的问题。我敢打赌，那些……我不知道什么是简单的。这里有很多事情要考虑，因为不仅仅是推荐算法，他们还必须处理整个内容审核空间，这变得非常复杂。
um yeah especially when you consider the i can't remember if it's billions of hours of content they get uploaded every hour every day or something like that yeah it's some it's some absurd number that's like unfathomable and they're like oh how did your moderation team not catch this and they're like moderation team like we have a moderation team but they they manually look at a fraction of a fraction of the of the content uh i didn't even think about this but but but like language has also got to be a a fairly big thing too right like you need to i don't know is it is that when you submit a video do you say what language it's in i don't think you do no but i think I think it auto-detects that stuff. Yeah, it's got to be pretty easy.
嗯，是的，特别是当你考虑到我记不清是每天还是每小时上传的数十亿小时的内容时。是的，这是一个令人难以置信的荒谬数字。他们会说“你们的审核团队怎么没发现这个？”，然后他们会说“审核团队？我们确实有一个审核团队，但他们只是人工查看了内容的一小部分中的一小部分”。我甚至没想过这一点，但语言也一定是一个相当大的因素，对吧？你需要……我不知道，当你提交视频时，你会说明它是哪种语言吗？我不认为你会。不，但我认为它会自动检测这些东西。是的，这应该很容易。
I think that part is pretty, like, you're not allowed to swear in the first 10 seconds or something. But, like, that, I imagine, is not actually a hard problem these days. Really not allowed to swear in the first 10 seconds. I think you are allowed to. But if you do, you get, like, some kind of not safe or something label. I don't know? I don't, I don't know. Cause I don't swear in my YouTube videos,
我认为那部分相当简单，比如，你不允许在前10秒内说脏话之类的。但是，我想这在今天并不是一个难题。真的不允许在前10秒内说脏话吗？我想你是可以说的。但如果你说了，你可能会得到某种“不安全”之类的标签。我不知道。我不知道，因为我的YouTube视频里不说脏话，
but I think there are certain YouTube channels that have like a part of their, like a catchphrase is like, you know, says some word that's on some, you know, not allowed list. Stay tuned listener.
但我认为有些YouTube频道，比如他们的口头禅，包含了一些在禁止列表上的词。敬请期待，听众们。
We've got Kevlin Henney almost lined up for next week. And we'll have a couple episodes of that. And then we'll probably be live from CBP North. If you're there, come say hi. All right, we'll chat next time. All right, I gotta get back to figuring out how Python decorators work. Be sure to check these show notes either in your podcast app or at adspthepodcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode as well as a link to a get up discussion where you can leave thoughts comments and questions thanks for listening we hope you enjoyed and have a great day low quality high quantity that is the tagline of our podcast it's not the tagline our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们已经安排了Kevlin Henney参加下周的节目。我们将会有几集关于他的内容。然后我们可能会在CBP North进行现场直播。如果你在那里，过来打个招呼。好的，下次再聊。好的，我得回去研究Python装饰器是如何工作的了。请务必在你的播客应用程序或adspthepodcast.com上查看这些节目笔记，获取我们在今天节目中提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个GitHub讨论的链接，你可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。感谢收听，希望你喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。低质量、高数量，这就是我们播客的标语。这不是标语，我们的标语是“混乱中夹杂着信息”。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。